qu'est-ce que c'est dites-nous l'un des yeux les plus
avancés au monde il est une
première version du projet je travaille
sur
ce que tu veux pour moi j'ai besoin de toi pour
terminer le projet et si je dis
non
alors tu restes dans  ma maison sera brève
et désagréable faire tout ce que dit Tao
j'ai reçu l'ordre d'infliger de la douleur
si vous ne vous conformez pas à mes ordres
il accomplira ces tâches il est temps
de commencer
elle attend juste que la police nous trouve
vous n'entendez pas non  on venait nous sauver
comment on sort c'est quoi cet endroit
Julia
Julia qu'est ce que tu fais
repond moi
tu dois me laisser repartir reviens a tes
taches immediatement ou je t'inflige de la douleur